welcome to playtime 2018 it's amazing to
see all of you here today in this
incredible space I look out and I see
familiar faces people I'm gonna meet new
friends today thank you so much for
being here it's ten years of Android
five years of playtime in Mia I'm
thinking look how we've all grown up
thank you for joining us from over 40
countries across Europe Middle East and
Africa my name is Shannon Lowe I head up
the apps and games business development
team for Google Play in amia we wanted
to kick off today with this I make apps
film because this campaign and playtime
both share the same spirit they're both
about celebrating you the people behind
apps and games the Android and play
community we all know that it's the
community that powers any platform
without you we wouldn't be where we are
today 2018 is an incredibly important
milestone for us because as I said
before Android debuted ten years ago on
a single device everyone remember
Android Market we had 50 apps in total
and of course those important barcode
scanners and ringtone editors that
everybody needed I'm sure there's some
folks in this room here who are working
on barcode scan as a ringtone editors
ten years ago those were humble
beginnings for all of us but it set us
on a good path a path for Android to
become the most powerful and important
popular computing platform on earth with
devices available in every shape size
and price point around the world as
connectivity has become nearly
ubiquitous we use our devices everywhere
for things that we couldn't have
imagined ten years ago and that's all
thanks to you you have changed how we
interact with each other how we get
things done and how I even spend our
time you created new experiences new
industries new economy is thriving in
communities all over the world
simulating employment inspiring
entrepreneurship our team is especially
proud of the work that you do here in
amia and it's great to see that it's all
paying off since the beginning of the
year the number of you based in our
region who are making 1 million dollars
or more per month on Google Play has
grown by fifty four percent fifty four
percent that's a huge leap and one
business model that's working well for
many of you is subscriptions
subscriptions revenue has doubled in the
past year and grown four times since
2016 at play we view ourselves as your
partner in helping you grow your apps
and games business we've made huge
investments in people technology
processes to help you succeed on Android
we're very proud of what we've been able
to accomplish together but at the same
time we realize that there's much more
to be done that's one of the reasons we
are here today to continue listening to
your feedback to share experiences and
to learn more from each other to tell
you more about what we are doing to
continue helping you grow your business
on Android and play please welcome our
keynote speaker Tian Lim our vice
president of UX and products from Google
Play
hi everyone good morning my name is Chen
and I run product and UX with Google
Play I'm super excited to share a little
of what we've been doing to help you
reach more users and build successful
businesses I'm actually still pretty new
to Google in literally five days time
will be my one-year anniversary at
Google and I joined because it's just an
incredible opportunity to help so many
people around the world both users and
developers one unique experience I want
to share with you that I had this year
was my short time in Nigeria we went to
Nigeria for the Google for Nigeria event
we were rolling out Google Station free
Wi-Fi for everyone and I had the
opportunity to meet developers and
influencers there and I have to say it
was just absolutely inspired I met
developers that Google trained and
became once they became certified
Android developers they were making 10
times more than what they're used to
make before or they were building
companies but local companies solving
real local issues the kinds of problems
that you can only solve if you're living
in that market here there's a a game
developer nestled between the YouTube
and movie stars and he's he has a small
game for kids teaching them African
languages and he found a global audience
basically the African Diaspora trying to
reconnect with their cultural heritage
these are some inspirational stories
that I came away with in my short time
there now this was just one small trip
talking to a few developers but here at
Google Play every month we talked to
thousands of you listening to you helps
us focus on what's important I wanted to
start the day by focusing on the user
and three things that they care about
quality safety and well-being
everybody here represents some of the
highest quality apps and games in the
Playstore you know that your investments
in quality pay off with highly engaged
users the flipside of course is a high
crash rate tends to lead to more 1 star
ratings on the Playstore we want to
recognize your commitment to quality and
that's why our search and discovery
algorithms now consider app quality and
user engagement
this means that apps and games with
better retention fewer crashes and fewer
uninstalls get recommended more
frequently to help you measure app
quality and improve it we have been
investing heavily in android vitals and
we have seen that developers that engage
with vitals can dramatically improve
their crash rates which directly leads
to better ratings and better engagement
now we've heard your feedback we've
heard the feedback that the data is
great but it's not super actionable so
today we are linking we pre-launch
reports with android vitals you'll hear
a lot more about this from Fergus and
Gavin but I have to say this is amazing
stuff what's going to happen is when
vital C's crashes out in the field that
we have already seen in the pre-dawn
report you can now connect these two
pieces of information together and see
videos and logs of exactly the kinds of
issues that users are seeing out in the
wild and so this can directly help you
prioritize which issues in the
pre-launch report to focus on because
you know that users are hitting these
issues
let's talk user safety another very
interesting aspect of my short time at
Google is seeing the many new and
creative ways that our adversaries have
come up with to abuse our users or
exploit our ecosystem but let me tell
you we're not having any more of this
we're working super hard to turn the
tide on this problem and this is an area
that I actually had to get personally
extremely deep on and I'm very proud of
the team and both the automated and
manual ways in which we fight this
problem every single day
it's really tough work but it's really
good work Android and Google Play have
always taken security and privacy
extremely seriously it's simply not
negotiable
every app and game undergoes an
extensive security review before they
are published using a combination of
both the machine learning automation and
humans and as a result 99% of apps with
abusive content are identified before
people can ever have a chance to install
them even after publishing Google Play
for text scans every app installed on
the Android fleet that's 50 billion apps
every single day that we're looking at
and checking for anything out of the
ordinary as a result of all these
efforts people who download apps
exclusively from the Google Play Store
are nine times less likely to install a
potentially harmful app so that's a
little of what we do for the safety of
the ecosystem but we need your help our
policies are constantly changing
adapting working to keep the ecosystem
safe for you and your users your input
is critical and my team and I are
extremely grateful for the active
dialogue that helps us strike the right
balance between user safety and your
ability to innovate our goal is to
ensure that users are aware of how their
data is being used and that that access
is reasonable so last week we announced
a set of changes around the SMS and call
finished call log permissions this is to
make sure that users who require
developers who request these permissions
only do so when it is absolutely
necessary and we spoke with many of you
to understand your concerns and I tell I
can guarantee that our final decisions
were heavily influenced by all these
conversations you can expect us to
continue to review all the various
permissions and these types of changes
with the community in the months ahead
we will also be working to ensure that
we give you sufficient notice to make
these changes and details on how to
implement them for example on November
1st and not-so-subtle reminder that we
will require all apps and updates to
target API level 26 or higher this helps
bring security and battery life
improvements to all our users and these
are the kinds of benefits that can only
be realized in the ecosystem when all of
us get onboard we announced this 10
months ago with explicit instructions on
how to comply we need you to be on top
of these and future changes so please
make sure that you have the right
contact information on the Play console
read our updates and engage with us as
we roll through these changes now we've
talked about high quality apps in a safe
environment but increasingly people have
been thinking about striking the right
balance with technology as well I for
one escape my technology by subjecting
myself to extreme endurance sports and
extreme amounts of physical abuse this
is literally what happens when I'm not
out here trying to help users and
developers I get shocked with 10,000
volts of electricity now our research
shows that well much of the time that we
spend on phones is useful and valuable
many of us still wish that we could
disconnect more easily that's why at i/o
this year we announced our digital
well-being initiative we added
capabilities directly into Android PE to
help expose and control our digital
habits we added a usage dashboard daily
at limits the shush gesture and winddown
and many other features all to help
people find the balance that they need
as businesses we all need to think
critically about the longevity of our
apps and games and how we can
sustainably engage our users without
burning them out yesterday I was very
lucky to attend a meet-up for the
sustainable engagement forum
this is an extremely robust conversation
with great cross-pollination between
different kinds of apps and between game
developers and app developers it was
really really exciting to see the
community rally around the calls for
sustainable engagement so to recap we've
talked about important ways in which are
improving the user experience through
quality safety and digital well-being
but how do we connect more of them to
you so let's dive into some of the new
tools and features that we've built
after listening to you in particular the
amazing potential of our new app
distribution model some new features to
help attract and engage new users and
tools to help you monetize your business
app sizes they've grown dramatically
over the past four years they have
tripled in size but as you know larger
apps reduce install conversion and
increase in uninstall rates and that's
one reason we built the Android app
bundle with our new format we're able to
serve only exactly the code and
resources that a user needs for their
specific device since launching an i/o
in May several thousand app bundles have
been deployed to production and on
average those apps are seeing a 35%
reduction in size compared to a
universal apk we are really excited
about its potential and you will hear a
lot more about the bundle and the
benefits of smaller modular apps in the
next session so we just we architected
the entire distribution pipeline to
deliver your apps more efficiently
but we've also introduced new features
to help you attract and engage new users
pre-registration lets you gather
interest for an upcoming launch in order
to help boost your day line installs and
since we launched in early access
we've generated more than a quarter
billion pre-registrations we're excited
that the program is now available to all
our app and games partners and it's
fully self-service in the play console
you will also now have the ability to
grant user rewards to views early users
and we've integrated pre-registration
with Google Play Instant letting your
users try a product before it even
launches you could see an example of
that here on the left with Looney Tunes
world of mayhem Google Play Instant also
supports premium applications as you can
see here on the right with you Miro
we've also made these instant
experiences easier to build with
integrations into Coco's creator and a
unity plugin that is now available and
we've done all this because we know that
Google Play Instant can help you with
user acquisition we also have another
new launch that will help with your
conversion it's been one of the top
requests from developers around the
world and that's to modify store listing
pages based on user country not language
so now you can do this quick example
here Halloween in the US coming up next
week and Diwali in India they're each
about a week apart but users in both
countries tend to have the device is set
to us English so targeting my language
is not helpful with country star listing
targeting you can now change the store
listing content based on the user's
country so here are right here the icons
and photos are not only different but
the descriptions can now highlight
different features we'll talk about
different events in the different
regions so now that we've covered some
of the new features to help bring users
into your app let's talk about helping
you monetize your business
our commerce platform makes it easy for
people to securely purchase on play in
over 150 markets your credit card direct
carrier billing PayPal and gift cards
that are available in over 800,000
retail
occasions subscriptions as mentioned
continue to be a rapidly growing trend
and we have a lot of features in the
pipeline but here's a taste of just a
few of them on the left in early access
is subscribe and install on details page
so as you can see this combines the free
trial signup and the install button and
it captures user intent to subscribe
without having to wait for the install
in the middle you see the EAP for pause
so a user may be going on vacation and
rather than let that user cancel and
turn out this gives them some control to
put their subscriptions on pause and
helps keep them with you on the far
right you can see planned change support
with price changes for existing SKUs
with deferred upgrade and downgrades
along with the strong growth and
subscriptions we're seeing more
developers adopt a hybrid approach to
monetization and one trend has been to
reward users for an action like watching
a video ad with in-game currency or
other benefits so today we're excited to
announce a new monetization type called
rewarded products the first offering
being a rewarded video format users can
elect to watch a short video and upon
completion are rewarded by the developer
with either in virtual with virtual
goods or in-game currency this new
offering is powered by Google ads
technology and it uses the same API
calls for in-app purchases on Google
Play today no third-party SDK is
required we're currently in closed beta
but we will share more details with you
in the coming weeks so we've covered a
lot in about 15 minutes and as you know
there is a huge range of existing
features it can be extremely tricky for
any of us to keep it all in our heads so
help you take advantage of all the tools
and programs we're launching the Academy
for app success
today there are now 10 courses with
information ranging from managing your
apps release to granting refunds and
going forward will be supporting more
languages and adding more content to
help you take advantage of everything
that play has to offer so we help you
check it out so now that we've talked
about some of the tools for growth on
mobile I wanted to touch on the broader
Android landscape as you know we
continue to push our apps to many
devices with where or less Android TV
and auto and across even more surfaces
with assistant today I'd like to focus
briefly on Chrome OS and how this
growing ecosystem is an exciting
opportunity for developers so
Chromebooks have gone from what seems
like the small experiment to being
available throughout the world they
range from traditional laptops to
convertibles and we've built all of
these in partnership with some of the
best OEMs like Samsung HP and Dell
they're available in over 10,000 stores
worldwide and we continue to explain
expand our footprint last week we
announced exciting new device the Google
pixel slate it's a great example of our
commitment to the Chrome OS ecosystem it
was designed to bring games and apps to
life with a brilliant screen and great
performance so let's take a closer look
at a couple of great app experiences
optimized for Chromebooks and pixels
flay Gameloft
wanted asphalt 8 airborne to give users
more precise control and because Chrome
OS treats is physical keyboard just like
an external keyboard on an Android phone
asphalt 8 was able to support keyboard
controls using api's from Android
platform SDK 26 the result was pretty
amazing a whopping 6x increase in daily
access for users on Chromebooks and a 9x
boost in revenue
the Gameloft team was so excited by the
strong results that optimizing for
larger screens is now standard operating
practice and they've just finished
optimizing the latest version the latest
edition in the series asphalt 9 legends
another app is Evernote the Evernote
team was extremely excited to use low
latency stylus api's to quickly
implement touchscreen handwriting and
enhance layouts for those wider screens
now without the latency their users can
really feel like they're drawing on
paper the result users of Evernote on
pixel book spent 4x more time than on
other devices so these developers went
beyond a mobile only strategy and they
adapted their products to serve
consumers on a larger variety of devices
and as a result saw massive increases in
user engagement so perhaps you have the
same opportunities and because Android
apps are available on Chrome OS you can
take your app and with very few
adjustments optimize it for these larger
screens and form factors so it's really
easy more surfaces a larger creative
canvas for you from the same binary I
can't wait to see what amazing stuff you
all come up with so that's about it for
me today although I talked about user
needs and some new things to help you
connect with those users to you the
bigger seem to all this is that we are
here for you you are all the inspiration
for our work so please use this
opportunity to talk to us and give us
feedback so that next year we can bring
forth even more announcements and
features based on your ideas and
inspiration thank you so much
[Applause]